welcome to cloud on air live webinars
from Google cloud we're hosting webinars
every Tuesday my name is Micah Trotsky
I'm a product manager in security and
today we'll be talking about container
security you can ask questions any time
on the platform and we've Googlers on
standby to answer them so let's get
started so we'll cover a couple
different objects today first we'll
start with kind of container security
101 why why are containers different to
secure of any VMs are then we'll talk
about the secure software supply chain
and deep dive into two of our newest
products Google container at the Street
vulnerability scanning and binary
authorization lastly we'll see what else
you should be doing in the space beyond
software supply chain how else can you
protect your containers running a
production so starting off with
container security 101 a lot of what's
needed to protect containers are
constructs that were already familiar
with there were some similar things we
have with VMs we still want firewalls
access management audit logging ids/ips
and more the concepts that you need for
securing your containers aren't
dramatically different but the mindset
of constantly rebuilding and redeploying
containers is what's changed so what
specifically is different let's let's
get that out of the way first in terms
of protecting in terms of how security
is implemented for containers first is
the surface of attack a container
bundles binaries and libraries as part
of the container image so you don't need
as much in a host image if you're using
containers as intended that host OS
doesn't have as much bloat which reduces
the surface of attack next resource
isolation this is built into containers
allowing you to easily allocate
resources like storage volumes to
certain processes using namespaces in
terms of permissioning containers have
normal access controls like you'd expect
for controlling access to shared
resources and restricting apps
privileges that being said containers by
construction are more powerful and have
a wider range of syscall that they can
perform in the kernel and lastly of
lifetime containers are meant to be
immutable and a frequently redeploy so
they're fairly short-lived in fact 95%
of containers left less than a week this
should make it harder for an attacker to
persist in your environment but it also
means that if something does go bad by
the time that you realize it the
effective container might not be there
anymore and you want people to do
forensics so what kinds of threats are
there to containers where we see you
know in the wild how do we categorize
these threats first is a set of threats
to container peripherals like credential
compromise in provincial escalation
this is about how to get the
Cabrera's API to do something that you
might not want it to do next is what
ends up running in your infrastructure
you might be pulling images from public
repositories or have dependencies
unsupported open-source code if there's
a new zero day vulnerability discovered
tomorrow how do you figure out if you're
affected and how do you quickly patch
yourself and then there are things that
we hear people get really scared about
things like dos attacks and flooding
your event pipeline or even container
escapes and this is how we're thinking
about container security at Google if
you think about that what kinds of
controls you can put in place for each
of these types of threats we end up with
three main pillars how you develop
applications how you make sure your
images are good to build an deploy and
how you protect your containers while
they're running so the first one there
infrastructure security is about
ensuring that your developers have the
tools they need to securely build
containerized services this includes
Identity and Access Management logging
secret management networking other such
tools the software supply chain is about
ensuring that you know exactly what's
being deployed in your environment and
that it belongs there this is about
securing the host image the container
image and the application code itself
lastly runtime security is about
ensuring that your Security Response
Team can detect and respond to security
threats to containers running in your
environment so today we're gonna focus
on that middle piece here the salt the
security software supply chain so even
if how you secure containers is actually
very somewhat of a mess except for some
of the differences that we pointed out
running containerized microservices
leads to a different security model you
have a fundamentally different mindset
to adopt which all argue actually leads
to better security longer term first off
containers are meant to be short-lived
and frequently redeployed rather than
pushing a single line of code change
rebuild and redeploy the whole image if
you have other processes that can take
place possibly like patching your OS for
example you can be constantly doing
these you don't have to have any Sunday
- am mainland's windows containers are
also meant to be immutable this is
really just the previous point so you're
not changing single lines of code you're
changing whole containers what that
means is that you have a single choke
point for everything that gets deployed
into your an infrastructure if you're
deploying frequently you can actually
really quickly see and control what's
being run in your infrastructure a
common concern about containers they
don't provide a strong way to contain
workloads or rather VMs have a strong
boundary like a hypervisor that's well
understood as a result users are
hesitant about running multi-tenant
environments that is deploying to
containers for different workloads on
the same VM
because they're worried about you know
one workload affecting another this is a
fair concern but no longer really true
with containers we now have technologies
like G visor that are specifically built
for meeting at this risk so the primary
counter-argument for containers is
actually now one of its greatest
strengths and lastly containers and
orchestration platforms like kubernetes
have security features built in a lot of
security changes when they're not
already enabled our simple config
changes you don't need to go build
something a new tool yourself in order
to move in something so altogether that
means that yes that your mental model is
different but you actually have much
stronger security properties so as we
talk about the secure software supply
chain today we're really focusing on the
first two pieces let's look at those a
bit more deeply the fact that we have
short-lived frequently redeployed
containers and that they're meant to be
immutable together this this dictates a
lot of what goes on your software supply
chain how is this actually different
well historically a monolithic
application running on a VM to make a
change your developers we need to SSH
into that machine or push code changes
without necessarily predicting the
impact that would have on the rest of
your environment what you see on the
left there there are manual adjustments
including for maintenance operations
like like restarts with containers you
can have a pipeline you can push code to
images which then go through your design
requirements for build test scan etc
until deployment micro services are
redeployed as individual container
images rather than changing specific
lines of code it's easier to debug and
it's easier to change and so from from
your code you might create a base image
that goes through your pipeline we're
gonna focus on today our two items that
you can integrate into your pipeline
between developing your code and pushing
into production
the first is container registry
vulnerability scanning you might want to
store certain image metadata as part of
your image repository including notably
whether your images have known
vulnerabilities and the second one is
binary authorization you might want to
enforce that your images meet certain
requirements before you deploy them to
your production environment so let's dig
into this first up container registry
vulnerability scanning
Thank You Maya hello everyone I'm going
to talk about container registry
vulnerability scanning essentially what
container vegetable an ability scanning
does is it scans your images in Google
container registry for known
vulnerabilities by checking the
corresponding security databases the
value in this is that enables you to
identify so you can address them and in
that way protect your application and
protect your customers and your
infrastructure currently the product
supports Debian Ubuntu on a bun two and
out point based images but we're
actively working on and support for
additional distributions like CentOS and
Red Hat what it does is once
vulnerabilities are found a alerts are
generated using our pops up integration
and they're also surfaced in our UI or
CLI and also we are api's images are
scanned as soon as you push them into
GCR and also africa after that initial
scan we continuously analyze them and as
new vulnerabilities are discovered
we surface that information for you so
you know when once you find Apple
durability using you CI out using modern
ability scanner how should you react
what you well as I mentioned the
information is made easily available for
you we are the UI the CLI and the API
you can also use something like the GCP
mobile application to set up push
notifications so you are alerted when
new vulnerabilities are found also with
pub/sub this gives you a lot of power in
terms of plugging the findings and
plugging the vulnerability information
into other parts of your workflow and
you can use some a cloud functions to
essentially enable a communication
between these different systems an
example could be using the pops or
notification information we are closed
functions to then generate an issue or
an item to track in your repo so at
someone is assigned to a vulnerability
and it can be further analyzed and and
addressed in terms of you know how to
mitigate vulnerabilities how to prevent
them in the first place there are three
general categories the first category is
basically updating your packages so
this is easier said than done but it's
very important for you to regularly
update the components that you used to
build your images as part of your docker
build images and your general build
process something as simple as you know
apt-get update and apt-get upgrade goes
a long way
during that all components are updated
and you're not exposed to previous
vulnerabilities category number two is
removing packages essentially if you use
a stock base image from Ubuntu or Debian
those coming with a large set of
packages and many times your application
wouldn't one need all of those to run so
it's important for you to analyze and
understand what packages do I really
need and then to remove the ones that
are not necessary and then the third
category is using a new distribution for
example alpine and Debian slim and are
much lighter and much smaller and by
using one of those if you're able to run
your application on those the attack
surface is significantly reduced and
your software supply chain can be secure
much more effectively by using one of
those so in terms of continued stable
and ability scanning to use it it we're
currently in alpha so you need to join
the container container analysis at
Google Group this is going to change
soon once we go to beta but basically
what you'll do is you you need to enable
the API and after you do that you'll
start to see information like basically
your images in VCR will be scanned you
see a status change to scanning and once
the process is completed you'll be able
to look at over the results and find the
number of all and vulnerabilities in a
given image like in the image in the in
the slide in terms of some basically key
definitions for vulnerability scanning
and note is a detailed description of a
vulnerability so for example you know
the severity of it this every score an
occurrence is information as to where it
happened where it was found
so for example what package it applies
to and a vulnerability result is the
summary of the different vulnerabilities
that were found in a corresponding image
basically the the summary result that
you see in the middle of the screen
there in the slide so now I'm gonna give
you a quick demo of the vulnerability
scanning UI and walk you through it
and here so here we're starting from the
console and then what i'll do here is
i'll search for container registry once
I go there I'll be able to see all of
the different images that I've pushed so
as you can see here I have different
categories of images are going to a
python-based images and in there you see
I've pushed three images the bottom one
used Debian as the base and as you can
see in the summary there five
vulnerabilities with fixes were found
and a total 509 well and abilities were
found in the summary page you can see
the scan results at the top which gives
you the counts for the total the ones
that have fixes available that counts
for different severity and then you can
scroll down the list and in each row you
can find the severity the score whether
a fix is available or not the package
that it applies to and also a link to
documentation where you can learn more
about the vulnerability something also
you can do is you can scroll through the
different pages to find all of the
information and you can also sort by
column so for example in this case I
sorted for the vulnerabilities that have
fixes available and then when you click
in a specific vulnerability you'll be
able to see details about it so for
example you see when I was created when
it was updated details how the
occurrence the note and importantly
you'll also see links to documentation
for the specific vulnerabilities so
you'll learn you know what remediation
steps you can take now going back the
second image that I pushed you start
Debian slim base so as you can see this
one has fewer vulnerabilities 51 in
total and none of them with fixes and as
I showed you before when I go through
the list of items I can see the overall
counts rows for each vulnerability and
clicking on each of them gives me more
details in terms of you know what what I
should do by going to the vulnerability
documentation page and then the last
image that I pushed pushed was based on
Alpine and as I mentioned Alpine is a
much smaller distribution much lighter
so in this case no no no no owner
abilities were found so what you can see
here is as you go through it
when you push images they are analyzed
the information is made available for
you and very importantly you are given
information on actions that you could
take by going into the beetle details
page on potentially how you can address
that vulnerability something all that I
want to cover is a graph as krafayis is
an open artifact metadata API that we've
worked on with the community what it
does is it enables you to have a
consistent way to store information
about the artifacts and the general
items in your build process so you can
reason about it essentially you can know
what artifacts you have whether or not
they have vulnerabilities you can store
that information and then you can also
know what's running in production what's
in different environments and based on
that information make informed decisions
to protect your supply chain as I
mentioned this is something that is open
so you can add new meta data types and
providers as your supply chain evolves
and grows it's an open standard that
we've worked on with contributors like
Jay Frog Red Hat IBM Black Dog twistlock
aqua security core OS among others it
gives you full visibility into the
artifacts are going to your supply chain
and their state and different metadata
and you can set up an instance to run
on-premises but then also our container
analysis API for invulnerability scanner
is an implementation of the graffities
open api and you can learn more about it
by going to Cal see how Hightower's
tutorial and github you can learn how to
set up your own instance and how to to
to run it and now a Sanders want to talk
about binary authorization
hello my name is saundra i'm here to
talk about binary authorization so as
Maya mentioned earlier that containers
give you a way to apply consistent
changes and avoid on-demand direct
manipulation of running production jobs
so in the container model developers no
longer directly patch updates ray start
running jobs instead organizations can
have a consistent way to apply changes
to any production workload be it
modifications or new deployment a lot of
organizations have implemented
streamlined
tests as part of their CI CD pipelines
to apply security as well as the
integrity tests to make sure that the
changes made in production needs their
requirement however this approach still
does not change the fact that deployment
controls is identity based ie
restricting who can deploy not
restricting what can be deployed so in
this setup organization is still
vulnerable to deployment of untrusted
code a developer could still potentially
build a container outside of the secured
build environment and deploy it on
production environment as long as the
developer has permission to deploy this
untrusted code would still go through
and affect running production jobs and
that's where binary authorization County
Bar Association is a deploy time policy
enforcement that uses signature
verification to allow you to define what
can be deployed in addition to
restricting who can deploy code it
integrates with the gke enforcement with
the chicory deployment API and it
supports both signature verification as
well as image whitelisting to support
various use cases such as making sure
that images are butte by trusted c SED
pipeline before getting deployed in
production environment
or only deploy images that pass a
certain security or quality test or only
deploy explicitly authorized third-party
images let's take a look how it works
Biron authorization works by integrating
with certain CI CD stages and record a
signature or what we call attestation as
the image passed through with a
particular CCD stage successfully so in
this example the puter would issue an
attestation signifying that the image
was Bute successfully by the trusted
puter similarly test would sign or a
test image if the image passes necessary
tests as well as vulnerable T scanning
if the image has passed necessary one a
vulnerability scanning checks the
scanner would issue a another attach
station by the time the image comes to
deployment there are set of evidences
that's already accumulated for the image
that customers can use to defend
policies and codify what requirement
must the image meet before it can enter
the production environment in this model
e also raised developer can try to
deploy something that does not have the
necessary attestations but this would
fail and an annotation will be added in
the auto log for this deployment attempt
so the security team can review this
incident later on we understand that
organizations don't just run in-house
boots off wears a lot of so exciting
runner abilities are found in
third-party software environment sorry
the binary authorization supports this
by giving organization security teams a
tool to define white list of what third
party imagers are allowed in their
production environment so that they can
have centralized control over the
software as well as different versions
of the software deployed on the on day
or
Asians infrastructure so in this example
the security team would define whitelist
only allowing a particular version of an
energy access as a team and secure
so when developer deploys this allowed
version of nginx the deployment goes
through because in it is allowed by the
whitelist
but if a developer either malicious or
accidentally deploy something that is
outdated not allowed by the security
team the deployment will fail again an
annotation will be added in the auto log
for future review our authorization is
integrated in kubernetes engine and is
now in beta to turn on you first enable
the pioneer authorization API and then
when you create or update your
kubernetes engine clusters you you would
turn the final authorization option on
then you will go ahead and define our
deployment rules in binarization policy
either at the project level which would
apply to all clusters in the project or
you can also define granular cluster
level policy override that would define
policy for a particular cluster we also
support image white listing either using
repository a particularly path of a
pattern of the image name a path or a
particular set of image digests as I
mentioned any violation of the
deployment policy failed attempts would
be recorded in the auto log and can be
reviewed later on in stackdriver
now I will show you
binary authorization in action by giving
you a quick demo in this demo we'll show
you two use cases one is important
deployment of sign images second is only
deploy whitelisted third-party
so let's start by showing you how
signature verification work we have a
pipeline here that's beaut human
claudi's in this pipeline there are two
attesting or signing stages signing
everything that's filled successfully or
standing something that is beautiful
tact or production ready code for the to
signing stages we need to corresponding
at testers created in binary
authorization so we have the buta
and a tag a tester each of the a tester
has its own private signing key the
public key is listed here but customer
will be the one managing the private
signing key that only the trusted stages
in the butte pipeline I'll have access
to that can produce this signature or
attestation so now let's switch to the
container to the project where the image
will be deployed and create clusters
with minor authorization enabled so
we'll have two clusters will have a dev
cluster where we'll deploy anything as
long as disputed by my trusted pipeline
I'll also have a production cluster
where I only want to deploy code that a
butte from a production tagged code so
let's go ahead and defined that in
binary authorization policy policies are
defined in terms of testers so the Tewa
tester that i created i would require
the buta tester ie anything field
security for the project as a default
rule for my production cluster I will
require both the buta tester as well as
the tag a tester aka
having the tagged attestation signifying
that it's beautiful tag source code
now that I have that define let's go to
our beauty I plan and start a beaut as
you can see that the beaut run through
the attesting the beauty attestation
stage but skips the tag attestation
stage because the code is not tagged so
the pipeline will not add the tag
attestation to it so let's go into the
console and take a look at what a pass
stations are created for the newly
created image so we did a query and here
the image has one viewed attestation and
let's deploy this image throughout the
up cluster take a look at the workflow
status yep it was deployed successful
because their cluster inherits the
default project rule that only requires
viewed attestation now let's try to
deploy the image on the product tester
on the pod cluster which requires both
the beauty attestation as well as the
attack at his station
as expected the deployment fail because
the image does not have the tagged
attestation sensor was not beautiful tag
code so let's go in and mark the code
for this image as production ready and
reviewed the image as you see the
pipeline skips ahead and add they tagged
a test station to the image now that
it's able to find a tag on the source
code and now let's try to deploy the
image to prod again
all right as expected a succeeds because
both attestations are present now let's
look take a look at how to run
third-party images on my infrastructure
or use nginx as an example so my
security team has deemed a particular
version of a ninja X as trustworthy and
want to make sure that everybody only
deployed this version of nginx on my
entire infrastructure but let's try to
deploy it um before we modify our
deployment rule as you can say as you
can see the deployment fail because the
images are not viewed by me so it
doesn't have the necessary
attestations well what we have to do is
to go into minor Association and add the
image to to the whitelist the voiceless
essentially says that in addition to any
images that has a write attestation high
write signatures also trust these
explicit list of images that may not
have so right at sa ssin in this case
third party images now that we've added
it let's try to deploy it again
deployment was successful um well what
happens if I try to deploy a different
version of nginx that's different from
what my security team are whitelisted in
the deployment policy the deployment
fails because it's a different digest
here is a link to binarization website
for you to learn more in addition to the
integrated deployment policy a policy
enforcement provided by an authorization
to create his engine what about
kubernetes deployment that you have on
pram or elsewhere we believe that
deployed hand controls is one of the key
security best practice for containers
that is why we provided a open source
reference implementation kritis that
will provide similar enforcement flow
for kubernetes deployment everywhere
Kurtis integrates with Gracias metadata
API that Hawaiian just mentioned earlier
and provides enforcement based on
metadata that we recorded in the
graphics API it performs the enforcement
using creative admissions controller it
is open source built with the community
it provides two parts it provides the
enforcement deployment time enforcement
similar to binarization
it also provides a signer that connects
metadata to attestations so in this
example the critici-- 'nor would examine
build or vulnerability findings
published in any gracias api and apply
custom logics to determine if the
findings are acceptable to your
organization if it is it would issue an
attestation that can be used to perform
deploy time enforcement
later armed binarization is now in beta
we just announced beta launch yesterday
so welcome to come and try and join our
discussion group let us know how you
like it
as I mentioned binarization provides
policy enforcement for gke
i deploy time both in terms of signature
verification as well as english
whitelisting we provide project and
cluster level policies via Gracias and
kritis it integrates with GTR
vulnerability scanning and cloud build
we also supports break last deployment
which I did not mention in my
presentation that is when if you have a
production emergency you are able to
make deployment that push through
deployments that do not meet final
authorization policy we are specifying a
break glass flag and this incidents will
be recorded and can review this later
this gives you the flexibility to
accommodate any operational anomalies in
your deployment flow we also have
partner support from popular security
tools such as twist lock as well as
popular CI CD - such as cloud base and
Jenkins so integration with your
existing say ICD pipeline should be very
easy in addition to all that we also
provide a open source reference
implementation that you can use for your
community's deployment outside of chikki
thank you so what's next Maya thanks
Andrea so you should definitely check
out container registry vulnerability
scanning and binary authorization
there's lots of other things you can do
to protect your containers as well
there's a lot of guidance you can follow
so we've tried to break this down by how
mature your deployment is first you have
to set up a cluster you're gonna want
some basic some some basic functionality
to provide user management and never
segmentation these include how you're
gonna access cube CTL how you provide an
access to your users using auerbach how
you restrict inter intra cluster traffic
with a network policy how you architect
your app and segment your cluster using
namespaces and how you bootstrap trust
for your cluster CA now that you're up
and running you're gonna want to
maintain some basic security hygiene
is about ensuring that containers you're
using and a nurse shall really leverage
their security benefits this includes
keeping communities and your OS packages
images etc updated and patched using a
minimal OS for a smaller service of
attack like container optimized OS or
costs on kubernetes engine using minimum
iam rules for least privileged private
IP addresses to limit network
connectivity of your cluster monitoring
access with audit logging and ensuring
that only the binaries that you deploy
you build are deployed that's buying
authorization once that's done prevent
known attacks these are common
misconfigurations in kubernetes or known
vulnerabilities that could affect your
cluster these include disabling the
Carini's dashboard because it has
privileged access disabling the default
service account token protecting node
metadata as am a current broader access
than needed in scanning r images for
known vulnerabilities for example using
container registry vulnerability
scanning and lastly limiting the impact
of a potential compromise this is more
traditional hardening and fine tuning of
your environment include setting up odd
security policy to limit what's deployed
in your environment protecting your
secrets
send boxing certain highly risky
workloads limiting the identity that
pods used to authenticate other services
and using a service mesh to enforce
strong a network protection between your
services so there's a lot here we'll put
a link up at the end where you can find
out more about you know hardening advice
for kubernetes but you know don't don't
despair there's there's a lot going on
in the container security space and a
lot you can do to help protect your
containers and so those are the two
items we really covered today right
binary authorization and container
registry vulnerability scanning or just
one piece of a broader container
security story so in addition to that
what we discovered today you know why
would you consider Crimmins engine over
running communities yourself from from a
purely security point of view well first
of all kun a's engine provides some
common security best practices by
default right there are more things
being built in and turned on by default
which is just kind of benefit from which
you don't have to manage yourself it's
always gonna be a little hard enough to
do for your specific application next a
lot of these new defaults and security
patches automatically and easily end up
in your in your deployment because
criminais patches you to the latest
master version automatically and you can
also enable node auto upgrade to get the
latest version running on your notes we
talked about containers enabling a
simpler patch management system for your
environment that's not really helpful if
you don't also patching kubernetes so
use something like node auto upgrade to
me that you and easier on yourself
in LA say it works with the rest of GCP
you can use I am audit logging be pcs
and other products that you're already
familiar with as part of your company's
deployment in binary authorization
Canadian registry of all in the scanning
they all work together as part of a
broader picture you can use on GCP so if
you want to learn more there's a couple
links here our general container
security overview and then the deep
dives on the two of the two products
that we talked about today and please
stay tuned for a live Q&A we'll be back
in less than a minute thanks
welcome back everyone and now let's go
over some of your questions first
question that we got was how do I use
graffities with Chris I'll take that one
so krafayis provides a open source
metadata format an API for users to
conveniently store and retrieve metadata
associated with containers credits
provides the enforcement piece of that
story
so can you can imagine that you use
Gracias to store metadata such as
vulnerability findings or verifiable
Butte record that describes how your
containers are Bute and then use kritis
to define how you want to enforce
deployment using those information
stored in Gracias
as we mentioned earlier that there are
you can have a locally hosted graphics
instance or you can have a gracias
implementation as hosted by GC P which
is the GC container analysis API kritis
or by normalization works with both
implementations with kritis we provide a
open source designer that you can define
what is acceptable in a water ability
finding or in a verifiable Boot Record
that you would generate attestation only
if an image has the recommended viewed
our record as well as one ability levels
which can be saying enforced a deploy
time
so in short graphics provides a metadata
piece that you can insert and retrieve
an examining metadata Chris provides the
deploy time enforcement piece and they
do work together awesome awesome
our next question is why use a central
metadata repository and why not put this
data with the container using labels um
the sorcerer for that is is because
containers are immutable and labels are
considered part of a container image so
when a label change the identifier of a
container would also change which is the
digest to digest
container is content-addressable so this
doesn't really work well we want to
attach mutable metadata such as image
findings vulnerability findings or test
results that are generated after a
container is beaut that is why we choose
to keep the metadata outside of the
image it will also make a decouple it
from image the repository and easier to
integrate with different systems that
you may have in your RC ICD workflow our
next question for you one does Warner
ability scanning cover Sentosa OS
currently it doesn't cover it but it's
something that we're actively working on
and we will really support for both
centaurs and Red Hat soon we'll share
more details in the near future but it's
one of the top requests that we received
and we're actively working on and
support for those two distributions next
question for Santa how should I manage
the keys for my attestation authorities
yep so you would manage the keys
yourself we currently don't have a key
management solution integrated with
minor associations so if you have a
tester that is doing the signing that a
tester would have access to the private
signing key and as a public key will be
uploaded into binary authorization
policy so that you can use the public
key to verify the signature as the image
get deployed but for now you'll be the
one managing the private key private
signing hits yourself next one what
partners can use with vulnerability
scanning so currently they're not
directly exposed in the GC are you
either I showed you but there's work
ongoing in the cloud security command
center that and there are integrations
happening from different partners
including twistlock for example and
basically in the CSEC you'll be able to
access the vulnerability findings from
different providers one provider is DCR
vulnerability scanning the other
providers are for example the ones that
I mentioned before and you'll be able to
see a full list of they and you'll be
able to organize these data in one
location and it's also aggregated
across projects so it's a it's a great
tool and I highly recommend you guys
look into it bullets discovered by GC
are all ability scanning applied to any
of my running environments it's a really
good question great questions on there
and that's a question that we fir
consistently as part of our
conversations with customers and it's
something that we're also actively
working on we understand that there's a
lot of value in finding a modern
abilities but then the the key impact is
knowing are these vulnerabilities in any
of my running environments and that's
why we're actively working on the
plumbing history to vulnerability
scanning and we also have more details
on that some but it's something that
we're actively working alright thank you
stay tuned for the next session see ecat
buting startup light nighter with GCP
thank you thank you
you